A BIG EMPTY PARKING LOT YOU CAN
COME SIT IN FOR A SEC.
WITH OVER 500 EMPTY SPOTS AS FAR
AS THE ICAHN SEE, TARGET'S
PARKING LOT IS THE PERFECT PLACE
TO STARE OUT, BANG YOUR HEAD ON
YOUR STEERING WHEEL, OR TEXT A
FRIEND, I HONESTLY CAN'T WITH
THEM TODAY.
YOU CAN EVEN PUT YOUR SEAT ALL
THE WAY FLAT AND THEN PUT IT
BACK UP AGAIN.
THAT TOOK A COUPLE SECONDS.
OR TURN OFF YOUR CAR'S IGNITION
AND LOOK AT YOUR BREATH FOR A
WHILE.
AND WHILE YOU'RE THERE, WHY NOT
MAKE EYE CONTACT WITH A STRANGER
IN ANOTHER CAR?
AND WITHOUT EITHER OF YOU SAYING
A WORD, COMMUNICATE THE ENTIRE
STORY OF YOUR DAY.
WANT TO KILL MORE TIME?
HEAD INSIDE.
YOU CAN WANDER A CLOTHES AISLE
AND THINK TO YOURSELF, OH, YEAH,
MASAMO.
PLOP DOWN BY THE BRAS AND ADD
RANDOM NUMBERS ON YOUR CALCULATE
LETTER OR GO TO OUR TOY SECTION
AND JUST LAY DOWN BACK THERE.
AND HERE'S A TIP.
CHECK OUT THE PLAY-DOH.
OPEN THE BLUE ONE AND --
SURPRISE, WE HID A FLASK IN
THERE FOR YOU.
BOTTOMS UP, GIRL, YOU DESERVE
IT.
SO THIS THANKSGIVING, TELL YOUR
PARENTS YOU'RE GOING TO GRAB
SOMETHING FROM TARGET REAL
QUICK, COME KICK IT, THEN GO
HOME AND TELL THEM THEY DIDN'T
HAVE IT.
IT WILL BE OUR LITTLE SECRET.
TARGET.
BUY YOURSELF SOME TIME.
>> YOU DO HAVE TO PAY FOR ALL
THIS, THOUGH.
>> WHAT?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]